DAVID MORGAN: So first off, I'd
like to thank the previous two
talks for running early.
That means all of my weeks
spent practicing this talk
to get it at exactly 25
minutes are now wasted.
But hey.
So I'm David Morgan.
I work in Zurich as
a software engineer.
But actually not
on the Dart team.
I'll talk a bit more
about that later.
And first off, a
bit of background.
Actually a white
background for you all.
So I've been writing
software for 11 years.
And throughout
that time, there's
been one main motivating force
for my work, the one thing
that I care about most.
And that's been
happy developers.
This is a picture of
a happy developer.
And actually, this seems to have
worked reasonably well for me.
And I think the reason
this has worked well,
and actually you've
heard the same message
in different forms
a lot of times
today, is that
happiness is strongly
linked to productivity.
And actually, I found
a good way to put this.
We like building software.
We really, really love
building good software quickly.
So what does this have
to do with object models?
First off, by object
models, what I mean
is the classes that
you design, that you
write when you are doing
object-oriented programming.
They don't have to be
terribly complicated.
In fact, simple object
models are often best.
And what I'll be looking
at is a simple object model
and how happy I feel
when I'm implementing it.
And for an example, I've
chosen a chat application.
It seems to be popular to
write these at Google recently.
But mine is not trying
to compete with those.
It's very, very simple.
Users are sitting
behind a browser.
They have code
compiled with Dart2JS.
And they're connecting
to a single Dart VM.
So really a toy application.
Now, let's design an
object model for this.
And particularly, I'm
going to talk about classes
that I want to send between
the server and the client.
So first off and
most obviously, I'm
going to have a
class called Chat.
This is what the client sends
in order to say something.
There will be a string
field, which is the text,
and a set, which is the
targets the chat is going to.
The server will handle this by
sending a ShowChat to everyone
who needs to get the chat.
And this will contain the user
name that the chat came from,
a Boolean as to whether it
was private, and the text.
Let's add a feature.
Well, we're going to want
to be able to log in.
So we'll have a class called
Login with a user name
and password.
And the server will
respond with LoginResponse,
which is an enum saying
whether or not it succeeded.
One more feature just
to round out the model.
Users will have status.
They'll be online,
offline, or away.
And they'll have a status
message they can set.
And in order for
this to be useful,
we have to be able to query
this data from the server.
So we'll have a class
called ListUsers,
and another, ListUsersResponse.
The details are not
especially important.
This is just an
example object model
that you could go away and
actually write code for.
And it would actually do
something approximately useful.
So let's code this thing.
And we'll start with object
models as I defined it.
And here it is in Dart.
Right?
Of course not.
But why not?
The reason why not is that raw
Dart classes and enums are not
especially useful.
They actually
don't do very much.
And there is a
whole pile of things
that I want my object
model to provide
that you don't get for free.
Let me just quickly
go through them.
So first and most obviously, I
want them to be serializable.
It's going to be kind
of hard to write a chat
application otherwise.
I want them to be classes.
I started by saying
that I'm doing
object-oriented programming.
I meant it.
I want all these
things to be classes
that I can have and
implement interfaces.
I can write code.
And in Dart, that actually
means I can't use enums.
It means I have to
use classes instead.
It also means that I
don't want to just write
a data specification and have
my code generated for me.
Because then, again,
I'm actually not doing
object-oriented programming.
I want them to be immutable.
You've heard from
the Angular team
about how push updates are
better than change detection.
Immutability actually works
really well with that.
There are lots of really
good arguments for it.
And for me the way
to do immutability
in an object oriented language
is the builder pattern.
So that's what I want.
It also means I'll need
immutable collections.
I want my object model
to have preconditions.
Even in this really
simple example,
it's obvious that I want
null checks on my fields.
There's no meaning for my chat
instances to have a null text.
Finally, I want my object model
to be composed of four objects.
And by that, I mean
that they implement
all of the optional
parts of object.
They are all hashable.
They are all comparable.
They all have to-string
so that if I happen
to want to compare them or
do any of those other things,
it just works.
So that was my
personal laundry list
of what I want my
object model to do.
I'm sure you have your own list.
It may be slightly different.
But what you have
in common with me
is that you don't
get them for free.
So here's my slide.
I think some people
actually laughed
when I showed this because it
doesn't do anything useful.
And what happens if I
actually implement those
features that I just described?
And I'll do that just
for the Login class.
Watch closely.
Ah.
Let me zoom that for you.
So this is actually
the minimum code
needed to do all of those
things that I described.
And this is a horrible,
horrible violation
of the do not repeat
yourself principle.
There is no way that your
code could be maintainable.
There's no way your
developers can be happy
if you write like this.
And someone already
used a slide like this.
But this is a different snail.
And this is how your developers
and-- apparently Google Image
Search turned up a
different one when
I search for it-- this is
how your developers are
going to feel if you
make them work like this.
So there is an answer.
And I appear to have given it
away in the title of the talk.
So source_gen for Dart
is a really good answer.
You may have
detected from the way
Kevin was talking about
it that he actually
created this package.
So thanks to him.
I'm just a user.
OK, so now we're going to go
into dangerous territory, which
is that I'm actually
going to demo this.
So what does it look like
if I'm using source_gen?
So here I am in my Dart code.
I've put all of these
classes in data_modal.dart.
And the whole thing, the whole
data model that I described,
including comments,
including code,
actually came to
about 150 lines.
So my toy example
actually turned out
to be a toy example
in the code, as well,
which is kind of what
I was hoping for.
Let's have a look at that Login
class that looks so terrible.
Here it is.
It's not a whole slide.
And the crucial
thing here, there's
a little bit of
weird boilerplate
that I'll explain a bit later.
The crucial thing is
that the user name
field and the password field
are mentioned just once each.
There's no repetition.
A couple of general things to
note about this object model,
I said I wanted
immutable collections.
I'm using the-- let me find
one-- the build collections,
which are very much modeled
on the SDK collections,
but provide immutability
and builders.
And I said I wanted to be doing
object-oriented programming.
Indeed, I have.
So there's this
interface, Response,
which is for everything
that comes back
from the server to the client.
And I've decided
that what I want
to be in common of
all those things
is that they're all renderable.
Which means, for example,
that this LoginResponse
knows how to display
itself on the client.
So that's what the code
has ended up looking like.
Let me just quickly
show this thing
working to prove
that indeed this
is a working chat application.
So let me connect
to it a few times.
I'm going to log in.
And I'll set a status message.
Contact.
Logging in over here, too.
And I said you could list users.
We can list users and get them.
I'm awary, apparently.
So this works.
And with that, that
toy model turned
into really a small
amount of code.
So let's switch back
quickly to the slides.
How is this working?
So I have my data_model.dart.
The key thing in source_gen is
something called generators.
A generator is something that
takes source code as input
and produces helper
source code as output.
And in this example,
I have three of them.
I have enum_class,
which helps you write
classes that act like enums.
I have built_value,
which provides
most of the object model
properties that I asked for.
And I have built_json, which
provides the serialization.
And these three generators
are working together to take
data_model.dart as input
and provide the helper code,
the boilerplate code,
as data_model.g.dart.
Now, there's one
thing really critical
to know about how this
works in practice, which
is that this process,
this source_gen process,
is running continuously.
Which means that as I
update the input source,
the helper source is
immediately updated, too.
And not just that,
it's updated quickly.
Absolutely crucial for
the developer experience,
which I'll demo in a second.
Now, there's another thing
almost completely unrelated
where source_gen is also fast,
and this is in the runtime.
The code that you generate with
source_gen is arbitrary code.
There's no framework
that goes with source_gen
that you're using at runtime.
So the code that is
generated with source_gen
can be as fast as the code
that you had written by hand.
So this really is generating
production quality code--
assuming you wrote
production-quality generators,
which I like to
think that I did.
So let me dive
back into the demo.
And I want to look at
the most interesting
of the three generators,
which is built_value.
So first, I mentioned
that .g.dart file.
You can see it's
being used here.
This is how the generated code
is interacting with the code
that I write.
And the other thing to notice
is this weird underscore dollar
thing which you see
all over the place.
This is just a convention.
This underscore dollar,
whenever you see it,
that means that this
is implemented over
in the generated code.
It's a hook into generated code.
So let's go back to
this Login class.
And let's look a little closer
about what's going on here.
So first off, this class
is written as abstract.
And the fields that you want
are declared as getters.
And then, the magic
is that we have
a factory that delegates
to an actual implementation
provided by the generated code.
Here it is.
Here's the boilerplate
that I didn't
want to write that's
generated for me.
You can see we're
doing the null checks.
We have a builder.
We have a quality hash
going to a string.
There's the builder class.
So I claim that this is
fast to use as a developer.
How fast?
Let's see.
Pretty fast.
So let's just do that a
little bit more for effect.
Add a list, too.
And what do we see?
We see all of the
boilerplate is there.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID MORGAN: That was almost
completely not my work,
I should say, having
not written source_gen.
But thanks for the applause.
So let me reset
that to where I was.
OK, so what did I have
to do to make this work?
What is the source_gen
generator behind this?
Let's go to
built_value generator.
So source_gen provides
this interface generator,
which is really as
simple as it could have.
You have a generate method.
What you get passed as input is
an element from the analyzer.
That's your source.
You also have build_step,
which is extra metadata
if you need it.
I actually don't for
any of my generators.
And what you return is a
string, some source code.
The first thing your
generator needs to do
is determine whether it
actually has anything to do.
So built_value
doesn't do anything
for libraries or for other
top level statements.
It only works on classes.
So my first check is this
element, class element.
If not, I return null.
And that's how you
tell source_gen
you have nothing to do.
If it is a class, we
go into a custom check.
This needs built_value check to
see if it's something that I'm
supposed to generate code for.
If not, return null.
Once you've determined
that you should
be doing code
generation, your job
is to extract the information
from that element.
And here, you have the
whole Analyzer API.
So we're doing
things like getting
the display name of the class.
We're checking if
it's abstract or not.
We're going through
the constructors.
We're pulling out the fields.
This is all a very nice API.
It's core Dart SDK stuff.
And once you've extracted
the information,
you just have to
generate the code.
So the built_value code is
actually not very complex.
You saw some of the
generated code already.
So in fact, I just concatenated
a bunch of strings.
There's really
nothing hard here.
If you were doing a
lot of code generation,
you might want to use some
sort of template system.
Now, the neat thing
that source_gen
is when you return
this source code,
it passes it
through Dart format,
which means that the
generated code that you see
is laid out as you expect.
The other thing
source_gen does is
it pulls together the output
from the different generators
that are running and gives them
little headers, like this one.
So that was the generator.
That was it working
on built_value.
Let me now do a
more exciting demo.
So what I want to do is
to actually add a feature
to this chat application.
I'm going to do
it live on stage.
Please bear with me.
And the feature that
I'm going to add
is that when you log
in to the server,
you can see chats that
happened before you connected.
And I'm pretty sure the only
way to get this correct on stage
is with test-driven development.
If you like test-driven
development,
you'll know what I mean.
So very first,
I'm going to check
that my tests are passing.
OK.
Now, a little aside,
a really nice thing
if you're running code
both Dart on the server
and Dart on the client,
is for this kind of test,
you can fake out any sort
of browser-specific stuff.
You can plug the server
and client code together,
and you can run very small,
fast tests that actually are
behaving like end-to-end tests.
And that's exactly
what I've done here.
So I already have a
test that Alice and Bob
can talk to each other.
What I'll do is I'll take that.
I'll make it into a test
that they can see the log.
And what will happen is instead
of connecting at the start,
Bob will connect after
Alice has spoken.
And then, he'll only be able to
see that if the log was there.
And this should now fail.
OK, so how am I going
to implement this?
Well, I'm going use a new class.
And to save a little
bit of typing,
I'm going to base it
on the ShowChat class.
This would be a good
time for it not to hang.
OK, so I'm going
to call it Welcome.
It's going to hold my welcome
message from the server.
And we're going to
have two fields.
One is going to be
a list of responses.
So this is the interface.
This is not a concrete type.
This is the list of any
response that the server
could have sent previously.
And we are going to
have a welcome message.
Now, the one bit
of code that I need
to write is how-- or
rather, one bit of code
that this class needs is,
how does this thing render?
Well, this is pretty obvious.
We're going to
render it by taking
the-- oops, bit of a mistake.
That should have been public.
We're going to render
it by taking the log
and map it to render
each of the responses.
We're going to join
with new lines.
We're going to add a new line.
And we're going to
add the message.
OK, so that's my new class.
And as soon as I saved
it, it's ready to use.
So let's go to the server.
Implement there.
We're going to need this log.
And we need to fill it.
So whenever we send a
message to everyone,
we're also going to
add it to the log.
Surprisingly hard
to type on stage.
OK, and finally, whenever
we get a new user,
we need to send them this log
message, instead of previously,
where we were actually
sending them a chat,
which is a bit rubbish.
So here, we see the
built_value builder pattern.
And what we notice actually
is that the log field here
is not just a list.
What it is is a list builder.
And so we have
all of the methods
that we might want to
mutate this list here
in line in the builder pattern.
So the obvious thing
that I'm going to do
is add all of my log to it.
But if I wanted to, I could
also do funky stuff like sort it
in line.
And actually, I should say
that this builder pattern is,
I think, the nicest
way to instantiate
stuff in Dart or
actually pretty much
any object oriented language.
It can be made
extremely powerful.
And Dart gets a real boost
from the cascade operator.
Builder plus cascade operator is
just an incredibly powerful way
to encode data or initialization
in line into your app.
So I actually don't
want to sort it.
This text field is
now called Message.
AUDIENCE: It's called Welcome.
DAVID MORGAN: Oh,
sorry, thank you.
Did I call it Welcome?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID MORGAN: Did I get that
wrong in the previous slide?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID MORGAN: I did.
Thank you.
I would have caught that
with a test, you know.
You don't have to tell me.
OK, so now with a little bit of
help, let's see if it worked.
That worked.
So the feature is
actually there.
But for those of you
who don't believe
in test driven
development, we'll
actually show it in the browser.
So this time so
I'm not cheating,
I'm going to close this tab.
I'm going to say, hi there.
Let me log in again.
And now when I connect, we
can see the log has appeared.
And I think that deserves
a round of applause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID MORGAN: So it
might be surprising
that an end-to-end feature
involving client code,
involving server code,
involving serialization
was actually added so
quickly and easily.
And the reason it's surprising
is because you're not
used to having all of the
boring boilerplate code just
appear as you type.
And that's really what
source_gen is giving me here.
So back to the slides.
And just to really
emphasize that point,
this is what I would
have written by hand.
And this is what
I ended up with.
And this is clearly
a pretty big win.
However, that was a toy example.
You may be wondering, how does
this work in the real world?
Well, as it happens, I actually
work in the real world,
unlike some of my
colleagues at Google.
And so my team
works on something
called AdWords for Video, which
is part of adwords.google.com.
But you almost certainly
know it as this.
This is the Skip Ad button that
appears on some YouTube ads.
We actually didn't
do the button.
Someone else did that.
But what we do is the
business-facing part
of this, the advertiser-facing
part, the website where
people buy these ads.
So you've heard some numbers
about dollar amounts.
This is obviously a large,
complex, critical business
application.
Just to give a quick
idea of the scale,
we have dozens of developers.
They're working on hundreds
of thousands of lines of Dart
across thousands of classes.
So certainly a
real world example.
And the idea that I've
described, generating code
to support object
models, is something
that we've actually been
doing for a long time,
since before we
started using Dart.
And as with AdSense, we've
come from GWT, the Google Web
Toolkit, which means
we've come from Java.
And in the last three
years, we've moved to Dart.
But what's interesting for
this talk is actually the way
we moved to Dart.
What we did was we moved-- we
took our object model with us.
So we already had this
code generation in Java.
We wrote equivalent code
generation for Dart.
And then, we could move
bits of our data model piece
by piece along with the
UI from Java to Dart.
And crucially, this meant that
we had our JSON serialization
for that data model
coming with us, which
meant that not only could we
do RPCs from the Dart code,
we could also pass data between
the Java, JavaScript stack
and the Dart, JavaScript
stack in the browser.
So these pieces that we were
deploying could work together.
Today, we have most of
our browser code in Dart,
as I said.
And I checked.
And we are right now saving
108,000 lines of generated Dart
boilerplate, which
I think you'll
agree we're extremely happy
that we're not writing these
by hand.
So starting to wrap up now.
I really, really
hope the next time
you see a skippable
ad on YouTube,
you straightaway think object
models in Dart with source_gen.
That would make me really happy.
But actually, the real message
that I want you to take home
is three things.
First off, code generation
for object models
is a really powerful tool
for developer happiness
and productivity.
I've worked on code
bases that don't do this.
Sadly, it's not actually a
very common thing, I think.
I've worked on
code bases that do.
And the difference
is that if you're
in a code base that is
doing this consistently,
then all of your object
model is consistent.
There isn't a case where
someone just adds a class,
and doesn't bother to
write the equals method.
Or adds a class, and doesn't
bother to write to-string.
They all behave in the way
that you want them to behave.
And if you want to
add a new feature,
you just add it to
your code generation.
It's a really nice way to work.
Secondly, source_gen is a
really nice way to do this.
It's a nice package.
It's a nice system.
We did this in Java.
And in comparison, it's easier
to write the generators.
That's because the
analyzer and Dart
format are doing really most
of the heavy lifting for you.
And it's nicer to use
as a developer working
on projects that actually
use code generation.
Thirdly and finally,
if you don't
want to write your
own code generation,
there are these quite
nice ones that I wrote.
Enum class, built_value,
and built_json,
you can find them all
via this link on GitHub.
And you can also find
the chat example.
You can play with it
yourself and see, in fact,
how easy it is to add
features to this thing.
That's it.
I hope that was
interesting and useful.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: David David,
thank you very much.
Wait, am I working now?
What was running
in the background
that handled the regen?
DAVID MORGAN: A-ha, I was
supposed to show that.
It was on my-- so
you didn't see,
but there was a little
terminal running
at the bottom which was running
this watcher script, which
is just continuously watching
and updating the source.
SPEAKER: Thank you much.
DAVID MORGAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So we have-- you've--
SPEAKER: Actually,
I want to add on
since we're a little bit early.
Just so people know, so
one is obviously source_gen
is actually a tiny little thing.
And the built_value--
DAVID MORGAN: You
keep talking about it.
Ladies and gentlemen, the author
of the source_gen package.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: No!
It takes a village.
No, actually, where's Jake?
Jake's probably watching at
home right now from Seattle.
He's the hero here because
he's like, what are you doing?
And Nate, they're like, PM,
why are you writing this code?
DAVID MORGAN: False modesty.
SPEAKER: I swear.
It's huge!
I'm the most modest
person I know.
Subtle political joke.
But so what I want
to mention quickly
is this is Analyzer based.
And you noticed we're generally
on disk right next to things.
And so you would have asked,
why isn't this a transformer,
right?
People that have done
transformers before in Dart.
So just a little sneak preview.
The nice thing about doing
things on disk this way
is that you can Control
click and go to it.
And if the generated
code ends up a bit weird,
you can debug
through it on disk.
And so I wanted to kind of
plant that in your head as
we move into tomorrow
and we talk about Bazel
and some other things.
We have a whole
story here around how
we think about code
transformation, templates,
code generation, auto code
generation, even how DDC
is generated.
We have a model
here around making
sure it's super fast,
it's incremental,
it's easy to debug.
So keep that all in mind as
we kind of step into tomorrow,
we talk a little
bit about Bazel.
And hopefully the code
lab from last night
will make more sense.